>>So the question is, how can I help?
That's a great question.
And what we've done with the Young Global
Leaders, Global Resign
Initiative Task Force is that we have 32 initiatives
that we're trying
to gain momentum here at Davos.
And you go to our website and look at it,
a redesignourworld.com,
redesignourworld.com.
And there are so many different great ideas
that the Y-GELS have come
up with, within values, within health, sustainable
economies,
strengthening economies, governance.
So please check out the website.
I think there's many things that you can do
on the local level
depending on your skills, your interests,
your passion.
The most important thing I think is your passion,
what you really want
to see getting done in the world.
So good luck and thank you for your contribution.